هناك ، وأنا آسف لخسارتك ، هذا
أمر شخصي لأنك تسافر حول العالم
مع الملكة وعائلتها لأكثر
من عقد من الزمان ، ما أكثر ما تتذكره
عنها ،
تعرف أنه يوم حزين للغاية
تعرف أنني أشعر بهؤلاء  نوع من الآلام في
بطني وكأنني فقدت أحد أفراد أسرته
وأعتقد أن الأمة بأكملها تشعر بنفس الشعور عندما أرى كل
شخص في جميع أنحاء العالم تعرفه
أنني قابلت الملكة طوال تلك
السنوات أه في Pomp و Pageantry ولكن
أيضًا خلف الكواليس  إنهم
وجوه مبتسمة سعيدة وأنا أفكر فقط
اليوم عندما التقيت بها لأول مرة ،
أمشي في كلاب كورجي على طول نهر
قلعة بالمورال
وتطاردني الملكة وهي تهرب
الملكة تضحك بصوت عالٍ كما تعلم  لقد رأيتها
ترقص معها في بالمورال وأرى
فقط الأوقات السعيدة التي تعرفها
تلك السنوات التي أطهو فيها الإفطار
والغداء والشاي والعشاء
للسيدة المدهشة
التي تسميها السيدة
المدهشة وأنت تتحدث عنها
لقد كانت الدعابة ذ  أنت تعلم وسط حزن
وجدية اليوم أن بعض
قصص فكاهتها
ستجعل أي شخص يضحك ، أعني
إحساسًا رائعًا من الفكاهة ، لقد
علمت أنها تمكنت من الوصول إلى أي شيء
تريده بشكل صحيح ، أي شيء تريده تراه
ذلك  بالطبع مع الطعام ، أنت
تطبخ الإفطار ، الغداء ، الشاي
، أي شيء
ولكنك تقول إنها لم تكن من عشاق الطعام ،
كيف كان الحال عندما تعمل لديها
لتطبخ لها ،
نعم عندما بدأت العمل في القصر لأول مرة.
هذا هو أننا سنحصل
على شامبانيا وكافيار
وكبد فوا جرا كل ليلة ولكن لم يكن
هذا هو الحال ، فأنت تعلم أن الملكة
متواضعة للغاية وهي سعيدة جدًا لمجرد
إقامة مأدبة رسمية حيث يجب أن
يكون لدينا كل هؤلاء  الأطعمة الغنية في القائمة
عندما تستمتع بملوك الملكات
الرؤساء من جميع أنحاء العالم ، أطبخ
لخمسة رؤساء مختلفين ريغان
كلينتون لكلا الرئيسين بوش بينما
كنت هناك ولكن عندما كانت بمفردها
فقط بعض السمك المشوي الدجاج المشوي
لم تكن أبدًا أكثر سعادة مما كانت عليه عندما
كانت تأكل شيئًا ما من
حديقتها الخاصة ، بعض الخضار كانت بعض منها
والأميرة مارجريت قد بلغت ذروتها من
أقفاص قلعة بالمورال عندما
كانت سعيدة